You
Thought it'd be neat
Kind of just wanted to test out the 3DL
So I hope that you brought your um your your lunch with you and
Yeah
I have a video next to me and Boomi is behind me sleeping in the bed
And I don't
Rain is just staring at
Slicking up at me asking if she can jump up
What are we eating? No, I'm not eating seafood
I'm not eating seafood
No, that's that's for a different place
I see where is it. Oh, this is me on this information
Oh
You ate your lunch already?
I
I hope that's not too distracting
Okay, I'm your lunch
Feel free to role play along
I have some pickles
I have some salami and some little bread and I have some cheese
And I have some more bread and cheese and eggs and grapes and apples
So we have a little charcuterie
We have a charcuterie. So let me let me um
would you
I think the waiter I already put put in the order for us
So the waiter should be coming over
with the charcuterie
quite quite soon
any moments now
Any moment now? Oh, there it is
There it is everyone. Why is it in my lap?
Um
Well
Compliments to the chef
Uh
Honestly, I was staring at this picture for the longest time. I don't know if it's AI generated. It just doesn't look real to me
It doesn't look real
Um, actually, you know what I'll do. I'll just I'll do something different
Let me let me make it
I
How does this sound I didn't mean to throw it at you
I'm sorry
There we go now I can place it on the table if you wanted to drink
Um too bad
This is all I got
On the time that I had okay
So I have some pickles
And it's called oh snap pickles
And then I have the hill shot. It's like punctual bulls for adults
I don't know. Is this expired but neat kind of looks weird
When is the use by date?
I
Used by 11 28 24. Okay, we're safe. I think for now and then I got the starbucks eggs and cheddar poaching box
I don't know if this is good either, but I'm gonna eat it anyways
But I have a little charcuterie
Let me get a fork
I
Let's try these pickles
You want some ambient restaurant noise, that's a good idea
Hmm
I
Don't
Let's cover the cat hair I can't eat that one
I
Have some ice water we reserve this whole place for ourselves
I I put a lot of money in for our specialty to reserve the entire place for the bottom
All right
I
Don't want a pretzel. Oh, I kind of wish I got pretzels. I would have been tasty
Actually, let me put on some
um
Restaurant ambiance
That's a good idea
It'll probably be copyrighted, but I don't really care
Milk steak, what's milk steak?
Sorry, that is a rainbow scratching
I
Can't spell restaurant
Can I just
I can't tell what's copyrighted
We'll do this one
You
It's two hours long
Is typing dmca free
They don't care they'll say it's dmca free, but
Wait, what if I
I'll let this one
This is sound effect and it's a little long
I
This one is cafe music that's good enough. This one says
Raina if you could stop that would be great
He's just staring at me and pauses
Who looks the like of course help yourself. No, she doesn't want attention. She just doesn't know how to use a letter that's proper
um
That is obvious
How is that how is the music is it too loud?
I
You are in a lunch date with me
I'm numb numb numb delizioso
Can't open it
I
Smells like farts
I don't know about that one goes
How about these little crackers?
Hmm
It's like your date that just chews really loudly
Surprisingly relaxing I'm gonna try some of this
Hmm it actually tastes pretty good. I don't think it's bad
You can pick stuff up with your fingers. That's what I'm doing
I have the microphone off the stand because I realize it actually does affect the sound
Somali usually looks a little bit weird. Yeah
Hmm
Do I have any like savory jam
Oh
However
Oh my god that is strong is this so good
Has distilled light vinegar
Water mustard seed salt white wine root pectin citric acid tartaric acid sugar and spices
I'm mixing it up
I'm gonna put some cheese on it too and a little bit of that salam
And we take a bite
Oh
This mustard is a little spicy
Of course riders
Oh
So what made you want to ask us out?
Well, you know, I just wanted to wine and dine you although there's no wine at the table
But I could probably make some appear if I tried hard enough
You deserve a little treat and I wanted to have some special time with you
Because I miss you
All right, I'm opening
Some grapes
Sorry that might have peaked
They're quite sweet
What about some apple
You think I look cute?
It's hard to eat with one hand and hold three do
I want a piece of
So how's your thing so far?
Are you gonna tell me
But can I make some right up here
I
Here you can
You know
Have a little bit of that
It's attached to me, but don't worry about it
A little tired and a little calm
A little good missing
I've been up since three day, yeah
Why have you been up so late?
But back from classes, I hope they went well
Finished work and then you went to McDonald's and you're playing Witcher 3 on a date of my beautiful, funny wife as you should
Work as usual
You just woke up. Oh, what are you doing?
I don't have midnight emails, so I don't somehow
So I don't somehow hungry is about to sleep understood
You messed up today. Oh, I'm sure it wasn't that bad. I'm sure you'll figure it out. Don't worry about it
For now, we can hang out and chill
This cheese is quite nice
If your noise is in the background it's because rena is going through the groceries that I got earlier
Because there's cat treats in the bag
I don't have my cat on this restaurant, but she did
I could put my ears back on but they make my head look bigger
Hmm
Now it looks like I have a monster earring
I have an egg as well
She's gonna fall
There we go, look at it that way
I have some everything
Seasoning
I like everything van Gogh seasoning it's fun to put on stuff
He'll bring me chocolates. It's funny because I actually got myself chocolate
So, oh wait. Oh, you guys did get me chocolate. You got me a Reese's. Oh, thank you so much. I appreciate you
You don't like boiled eggs
That's like it's one of the ways that I like eggs. I I don't usually eat eggs, but I don't mind boiled eggs
I hope you like your new mouse. Did someone get me the mouse? Did you get me the mouse? Thank you
Oh, thank you for the present. You guys come bearing gifts
I take you out for lunch and you're giving me stuff
I
Can't open this
Using my teeth, okay, I did it. So I bite a little bit of the boiled egg
And then I pour a little bit of that every campaign because you sing on it
I
Highly recommend
Should try it sometime
You've never had a boiled egg
As I joke on it, where are you from to never have a boiled egg
How
Crack the egg raw right into my mouth. Yeah
It's stronger than salmonella and open a little peanut butter thing
Oh
It's um honey peanut butter
That's very tasty. It's from adjusting honey peanut butter. This peanut butter is really good
You never had a boiled egg either
We're never had egg in general
Because that's surprising
I'll see either. Oh, that's okay them
I
Have an apple yeah, I'm not the biggest egg fan either
I'm the same way I'll eat it if it's given to me
I'm not really a fussy eater
Like I'll still eat stuff. There's like a lot of stuff I
It's not really anything I really don't like
Have a little sweet grape
I
Very tasty. I think I'm gonna put some more Dijon most out
And then
And then we'll put it in bite
I think I'll put this all together
Cotton candy grapes. Yes, I have cotton candy grapes. I think they're too sweet though
Because I don't really like I don't like cotton candy
Too much sugar
I
Never eaten frozen grapes
Can you pat me no no patting
Yeah, you have going to a fancy lunch day for drinking cancel monsters funny
Yeah
No pet only kiss only smooch only smooch is allowed
Smooch right on the cheek. I know I can't really turn to the side right on the cheek right there
Oh
I think it's time for another pickle
Yeah, I'm sorry you can't have a pickle
You
Now see you don't like the smell what did I tell you it's vinegar lady
Let's do some more egg
I lost a piece of egg
It's fine Reina is sniffing it so probably
No, you can't come up here
I can't help up. I'm sorry. We're gonna knock everything over
Everything over
Yeah, you want some egg
No
And your your date feeds her cat under the table
Oh
That's a good ice
There's a does the microphone sound better by the way
Yeah, it's not too quiet anymore is it
I
Perks over serving the place it's part of the charm
Hmm perfect and glab
And now I know how to turn off ac koon when I do ASMR so they won't make a lot of noise
And I have a program to get out any other background noise and the hum
The hum is actually not even um
Going on at all. I think the hum is from my neighbor's ac
And sometimes it will vibrate through the whole building
Which could be kind of annoying because I am very particular about sounds
And it's just a droning. I don't like repetitive sounds
um
It's like a droning sound and so I usually have to put on rain noises. So I don't hear it
I can't get a pickle out
No, we lost the pickle oh my god help
It's hard to do with one hand. Can you feed me a bite?
Can you feed me your pickle? Okay ready? Uh
The pickle in my mouth
Delicious
I like that little um emoji a little dinosaur it's always makes me laugh
Good good good good. I'm glad I'm glad it sounds good
Yeah, what are you doing?
I know you can do one. Okay hold on one moment
I
Ignore the fact that my skin is the wrong color, but whoo and that this is a spoon take a bite
Take a bite
Pretend this is I'm scooping you some charcuterie on the spoon
I
Enjoy
You like it is it good
That's a ladle now it's not I don't just carry a ladle in my purse
The table's attached to her face
You know it doesn't seem to be attached to your face later today
A sleeping mask because you snore loudly
I got you
He's doing kind of travel
I take you on a nice dinner and I buy you monster and a charcuterie and you're worried about how big my arm is
I'll have another apple
You can snore in our mini because I snore a lot. Yes
Oh
If they're not as cute it's okay, I it's okay. I still I still love you even if they're not as cute
Even if you're a loud snore
I
I fed fear a small piece of cheese. This is quite cute to watch you eat it
So we have some more grapes
Um
Yeah, I told you to bring lunch
Oh beetle juice or alien
I really liked alien
I'll probably go see beetle juice by myself like I saw an alien by myself
This time I'll bring the hair on plush with me
I don't people would definitely think that I'm special needs, but it's fine
Yes
Yes, I still sleep with the plot
Oh
Yeah, I um
Went on my other account so I could retweet my asmr and then I realized in me tagged me in the photo and I was like
Oh my god
That's so cute
I'm no longer sleeping in the human dog bed. I am simply sleeping in my bed and fia is with me fia. Where are you going?
Do you want an apple you can't have an apple but you she's like trying to smell everything I'm eating
Oh
Whoa Costco hot dog
We're Costco guys we have giant hot dogs
I didn't I didn't give any that pickle
If you
I'll give you a nickel if you tickle my pickle
I
Sorry, I'm reading the chat
Oh true five dollars Tuesday, that's right
My dad
Usually gets free tickets for some stuff so he'll give me the free tickets because um
For his job, they'll usually get free tickets to take people out, but they just never end up using them
So he's like you want these and I'm like, I guess
The last time I paid the 20 bucks for a ticket that was ridiculous, but it was worth it. His alien was super good
Oh, I hope you feel better. I'm sorry you have a cold. You should listen to my takes care of you ASMR
I haven't done any members ASMRs I realized I should probably think about one to do
Okay, I am essentially done with food. I don't think I can eat these pickles because they're very acidic and my tummy is starting to hoard
Can I take you to the theater?
Yeah, if I see beetle juice, I might not stay long to go with me, but I think she might be busy
We have made plans to take all of out
I am taking them out to dinner because I wasn't able to make it to my friend's bachelorette party
Okay
Hey
I'm just gonna keep the mustard right there because I don't know what to do with it
Stop you're making me blush, man
You can't carry out like I kicked out
Hey
Any reveal they're going going where to look your turn. No
They don't live near me if they did we'd be hanging out all the time
I
My baby blue eyes
although
You do you still think my eyes are pretty
It's funny you get used to seeing something for so long it kind of doesn't
It kind of just looks weird
So now like my red eyes look so
Different
And then I look so pale when I am mom
I'm so pale
This looks like I have crazy tan lines
Isn't it funny
I am enjoying lunch
You
Get a bit closer no respectful distance. There's a table between us. I don't understand what you're asking for
Yeah, I changed the stuff around
So
Um
I actually asked I have to ask strongly about new reference sheet with me tan
And I would like I think I would like freckles and beauty marks
Because it'd be so funny
You're sitting on the table eating my scraps Mari
You're like, are you are you my little bug again our little bug pet of me and Chai?
Oh today is today thursday
It is yeah tomorrow we have a collab
He's like my little nickel nickel necklace
You're pouring on the team
Mari is one of the castle of the table
I know it's like uh, it seems like a lot of people like the freckles. So I like the freckles
Here you fall asleep
They'll finally meet me again chat all of the freckles why am I mean cute girl because I am a cute girl
I
That's so bad
That's so bad being a cute girl
I need to pull my nose
I got ready today
and I'm wearing
I'm wearing a black t-shirt and I did my makeup of
alternative
In e-girlie
And I feel cute
Yeah
Would you like my dirty tissue?
Do you mean the bundt speak voice
Again, I use my bundt speak voice when I'm happy
Yeah
Yes
No, but you'll pick it anyway, are you gonna sell it you see my good type of guy to sell it
Okay, my desk is now cleaned off
Oh
Wait, I forgot I have a racy's hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on
Um
That could stay there. Um, I need a word from PMG
I
Don't get out of there. Can I please copy it
Show her clip did someone say show her clip
I only pay for canva so I can do the background remover and make my really crappy thumbnails
Oh, my tummy just is great. I'll probably put my mic to my tummy
So
Did you enjoy that
I
Could you hear the tummy growls
Okay, I'm gonna wait for them to bring out the uh the dessert
Oh dessert is here
Could you would you like the lip?
Oh, I'm moving the table. I'm sorry. I'm just so excited my my peepee lifted the table
Look
Let's make it a little smaller this restaurant is really high class
Really high class
Which half of the racy's do I want the top of the I'm not splitting it with you. You have your own
Here here's yours
See they were just stacked on top of each other there's yours here you can you can take it take your take your racy's
here
I'm not cutting the crust off of your racy's
Oh
The crust is the bath is the bath as part am I packing? I'm always packing
I'm always packing when you're talking about I don't know what that being noises. I'm always packing. Don't worry about it though
I'll put it away. You're allergic to racy's so that's that's a shame
That's that's a that's a that's a shame. I'm so sorry
Looks like you're dying today. Looks like you're consuming those racy's and going into that anaphylactic shock
It's a king-size racy's I'm only gonna eat by two
Racy's are an american
They are my family's favorite
My parents are
lose
For racy's if you want to win my parents affection
If you want to ask for my hand in marriage and offer my parents both racy's
I
Love peanut butter
Amy doesn't like peanut butter that much so you believe that either to some of the other girls
Hmm
Rare veal or elf
We're starting to ruin the state
I
Almost ate the wrapper
Don't you people like peanut butter when the apocalypse apocalypse comes you're dying first
I
Eat peanut butter off of a spoon too
What I do is that I um I'll put like peanut butter and nutella on toast
With banana and some chia seeds
Oh, I think it's some ice munches
Okay, I'm not gonna lie to you bros. I'm gonna eat these other racy's
I haven't had chocolate in a while
She had a
No, let's get my dad peanut butter whiskey screwball that stuff tastes like trash
I'm not gonna feed my dad that garbage and he knows it
And there's a civil war
And it's the peanut butter lovers against the non peanut butter lovers
Are people with allergies? I'm sorry you guys aren't gonna make it
I'm sorry, I don't like alcohol that much. I'll be honest with you
I
What is your favorite brand of peanut butter if you like peanut butter here
I do
I
This the stream is your favorite flavor of his favorite brand of peanut butter
Australia members Peter Pan, honey
Interesting
Store brand I like jiff jiff reduced fat peanut butter
I
Don't like skippy peanut butter because I don't like the packaging
I don't like the color they have it bothers me. I don't know why I can't explain it
I just don't like how it looks so I don't eat
Yeah, you cannot have a Reese's
I like jam I like putting jam on my English muffins and crumpets. Have you ever had a crumpet?
Yeah, but the branding of skippy, I just don't I don't know
Pumpet
Powdered peanut butter
No, I like jam jam. I like raspberry preserves. They're my favorite
Butter and honey that sounds good
I
Don't really eat jelly. Jelly is like jello and I don't want the texture
Which is weird because you know preserves usually has like the seeds and everything in it, but I like it that way
Makes it feel more real
All right, it's ice crunching time and then I will send you off to straw knee. I like peanut butter and honey
You
Taking you home
But the puns
I
Don't know I just wanted to say that depends and leave you in suspense
I like french toast and waffles and pancakes
Actually waffles and french toast are kind of even for me. I don't like pancakes that much. Well, I like I'll eat them
So I don't like it's not that I don't like them. You know what I mean
It depends on it just depends
I
Like chicken and waffles chicken waffles are really good
You know, I wanted to do I think I wanted to do a watch along of um
Love island
Because going on the dates and stuff. It just made me think about
I haven't watched love island in so long and I love love island
I got my mom into love island
But I did make it to waffle house
I
Actually prefer plain pancakes
But I like to put stuff on top
So
Ah
Well, this was a nice date I'll play I'll take the check don't worry about it. It's on me
Let me get this Reese's off the table
Did you finish your monster
I'll get they took that away for me
I got it. Don't worry about it
Let me uh
Let me look at the receipt pretend this is a receipt. Okay. Just pretend this is a receipt
Oh
Wow
That's a receipt all right. This looks weird
anyways
I
But it's fine. Yeah, let me let me pass. Where's my card?
Let me just grab my card
Let me grab my card it's a log here somewhere
I swear I'm not oh here it is. Here's my credit card
There you go
There you go. Wait. Oh, okay. They took it
Quick we got to go we got to go. It doesn't have any money on it. We got to go. We got to go. Come on. Let's go. Come on
Let's go. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go
Why are you doing come on?
You gotta go. What are you doing? Why are you just sitting there?
No, we got to do it before they come back
Okay
I don't know why we're so small
We got to go
You see this you're just gonna sit there. You're just gonna sit there. You're just gonna sit there
Yeah, at least this is how you wanna
You really want to do that
You really really
No, you don't have to pay for it. Don't worry about it. Don't worry about it. Let's go. Let's go